based on what we've done in the last two
videos we've been able to figure out
what the marginal revenue curve looks
like for the monopolist here for the
monopolist in the orange market and this
is what we got right over here it was
aligned with the slope twice is twice as
steep as the slope of the demand curve
and we'll see that that's actually
generalizable there's an optional video
that I'll do very shortly where I prove
it with a little bit of calculus but
it's very important to realize that this
marginal revenue curve looks very
different than the marginal revenue
curve if we were dealing with perfect
competition if we were dealing with
perfect competition there would be some
equilibrium price in the market and all
of the competitors would essentially
just have to take that price so let's
say that that equilibrium price was
three dollars per pound
then our marginal revenue curve would
look like this if we were not a
monopolist if we were a a one of the
many perfect competitors I guess you
could view it that way because we would
just have to take that price if we
wanted to sell 1,000 pounds each of
those out each of those pounds we would
get three dollars per pound and then if
we want to sell 1,000 one we'll just get
three dollars per pound for the next one
it doesn't change we're just taking that
price with the monopolist things do
change because we are the only producer
in the market the price at which we can
get changes depending on what we produce
because we are the entire supply for the
market and we have this downward sloping
marginal revenue curve now with that out
of the way let's think about what will
be the optimal quantity for us to
produce if we wanted to maximize profit
and if we think in pure economic terms
that's what firms try to do they try to
there exist to maximize profit and to do
that we're going to have to think about
and remember it's not to maximize
revenue to maximize revenue we would
have said oh well they should just
produce three thousand pounds but it's
not about maximizing revenue it's about
maximizing profit we have to take the
cost into consideration and to do that
we'll have to draw a marginal cost curve
and so let's say I did the research
let's say we're the owners of this firm
and we have a marginal cost curve that
looks something like this
let's say our marginal cost curve looks
like this it's important to realize we
are the we are the market we are the
only producers here so this isn't just
our marginal cost curve this is a
marginal cost curve for the market or
another way to think about it
this is the supply curve for the market
it tells you at any given price how much
the market is willing to supply you
could view it as a marginal cost or you
could view it as a supply curve and
we've talked about it before you can
view a supply curve as a marginal cost
curve if you want some if you want the
market to produce one extra pound what's
the minimum price you would have to give
that is the marginal cost
now with this out of the way let's think
about what you would produce well you
would definitely you would definitely
want to produce something you definitely
start to produce a few a few pounds
right over here because the marginal
revenue you're getting is way above your
marginal cost each incremental pound
you're producing right over here you are
getting much more revenue you're getting
you know five or six dollars of revenue
and it's only costing you a little over
a dollar it's just like okay I'm going
to keep producing I'm going to keep
producing over here you're still each
incremental unit you're getting you're
still getting more revenue than the cost
of that incremental unit and that keeps
being true all the way until you get to
all the way until you get to 2,000
pounds right over here at this point
right over here you don't want to
produce an incremental unit because if
you produce one more unit if you produce
that 2004
right over here then for that two
thousand and first pound your cost is
going to be slightly higher than the
revenue you get in so you will actually
take a slight loss on that so you will
your your total profit will start to go
down and you don't want to produce less
than this because you'll be leaving a
little money on the table you'll be
leaving that little incremental pound
where the total revenue was just
slightly higher than or the marginal
revenue on that incremental pound was
just slightly higher than your marginal
costs on that incremental pound so you
will produce right over there now this
is interesting because this is a
different this is an a different
equilibrium or ggest we say this is a
different price or this is a different
quantity or this is a different price
and quantity than we would get if we
were dealing with perfect competition if
we were dealing with perfect competition
our equilibrium price and quantity would
be where our supply and demand curves
intersect it would be right over here it
would be a price of $3 per pound and a
quantity of 3000 pounds now in order to
maximize profit we are intersecting
between the Marj
revenue curve and or our quantity that
we want to produce as a monopolist is
the intersection between our marginal
revenue curve and our marginal cost
curve which is right over here and so we
can see that there is a deadweight loss
there is a deadweight loss by hat being
a monopoly although it's good for us is
good for the monopolist it's not good
for society at least in this example and
there's very few where I can imagine it
being good but I guess there are a few
if you're trying to kind of protect a
national industry or something like that
over here this is the quantity that we
are deciding to produce the consumer
surplus the consumer surplus is the area
above the price and below the demand
curve so this right over here is the
consumer surplus consumer surplus the
producer surplus is looking pretty good
and this is essentially what we're
trying to optimize our producer surplus
is this whole area our producer surplus
is this whole area right over here
producer surplus right over there but we
have a deadweight cost there's a total
surplus that we would have gotten if we
went to the society would have gotten if
we went to the if we went to if we were
dealing with perfect competition right
over here that's now being lost but as
we lose that we were able to increase
the producer surplus and decrease the
consumer surplus so it's beyond just
having this deadweight deadweight loss
over here it's also obviously given much
more value to the producer to the
monopolist and given much less value to
the consumer